[Music]
you
[Music]
hi my big secret is that I just read the
John F Kennedy assassination report and
found out that my grandfather Edward
Grady Parton may have been behind the
president's murder that's big news to me
and I hope you have a beautiful day a
[Music]
few years ago I found out that my
husband was gay and cheating on me with
men and that he was using a lot of drugs
and I'm still with him I've been
together for like five years since then
I don't want to tell anybody didn't want
anyone to know
[Music]
I've had to secretly I guess keep it to
myself that I'm bisexual for 18 years I
[Music]
just decided that I need to leave my
husband
[Applause]
I'm trying to leave but I can't so a
couple years ago my great grandmother
passed away and so when I went to
Florida for the funeral after the
ceremony
my grandmother took my great
grandmother's ashes and went to where my
great grandfather's ashes were and she
put them in the same grave which was
ironic because they got divorced when my
grandma was 10 so she didn't tell
anybody about it but it was her last act
of trying to get them back together
[Music]
I'm sure most people don't know this
about me but I was arrested once and
taken to jail
there was a fight going on in the front
yard of a party and I went out on the
front steps not knowing that in a
condominium the front steps are of the
property they don't belong to the condo
owner and I had just grabbed a beer and
instead of breaking up the fight the
police came around through the bushes
one policeman and grabbed my wrist and
broke my watch band and it was a very
special watch my parents had given me so
I leaned down to get the watch and the
policeman turned a dog on me I pulled
away and then I was arrested for
resisting arrest put in a paddy wagon
then we got to the police station they
locked me up but I understand police
brutality
I understand being arrested when you
haven't done anything wrong and I'm very
sorry for anybody else who has
experienced this music cadet though is
okay
estoy muy in ojala por que no puedo
Yala's Manifesta Sione's in contra el
assessment for my situation in El Pais
[Applause]
[Music]
I have been lying on my resume that I
was a double major ever since I
graduated college and that I had a 3.5
GPA it was definitely not the case more
of like a C student all right my secret
is that I'm completely illiterate I
never learned how to read or write all
right I have an imaginary friend which
is my right hand and his name is Jeff
and I am double-jointed in both my
thumbs so it kind of freaky I am
partially red-green color blind I
secretly fear that I have created my
son's behavioral problems
anything negative about my son is my
fault I love my family but I'm
absolutely terrified of my fault there
[Music]
my secret is that my parents think that
I spend the rest of my life with them
and I will just be with them every step
of the way but in reality I know that
once I become an adult I'm gonna get
away as far as we can when I was 17 I
lived in a small town in Texas I
attended a party where I was jumped by
three men after I came out as homosexual
they cornered me they asked me questions
about my sexuality and when I tried to
walk away one hit me over the head I
don't remember or recall anything after
that however I was told by my friends
who saw the whole thing go down that
they had me on the ground and they were
kicking me repeatedly I managed to get
up and run away and I soon realized that
my face was completely shattered and I
had to have multiple reconstructive
surgeries on my face and has taken me 16
long years to get to a place where I
finally feel like I am who I was meant
to be because of this it took a lot of
soul-searching
a lot of courage and God but I managed
I have a dog and I love my dog but
sometimes I wish that I didn't have a
dog so I don't know if you're familiar
with Giardia but it's an intestinal
parasite and my this is years ago my
ex-boyfriend got these shelter cats and
one of them was kind of sick the cat
would get up in the middle of the night
just screaming it reminds me of the
scene in bridesmaids where she was just
like hoping in the middle of the street
and the dress like no like it's
happening it's happening that's what the
cat was like so I'd always be the one up
in the middle of the night to take care
of the cat sure not the cat had Giardia
no surprise there and a few days later
like my stomach just felt weird and I'm
like oh no my bowel movements look weird
I was like oh god I have Giardia it this
is it it's happening I remember like
telling my ex-boyfriend he's like no
you're just a hypochondriac you just
think you have Giardia like yeah I don't
know I just it's different like I know
humans can get it I just I just really
feel like I had it someone did like a
really busy day at work and I'm like out
to lunch or grab a burrito I like
running back to the office trying to eat
my burrito fast get on the call I was
interviewing someone for position and
I'm on the phone actually at the time
with my ex-boyfriend just chit-chatting
and all of a sudden I'd go like I had to
go and I was talking to him I'm like I
gotta go I just hung up the phone and I
couldn't even explain and I'm like
running out of office and like the
bathroom is like outside of our office
suite down the hall and I'm running to
go to the bathroom and as soon as I
grabbed the door to go out in the hall
I'm just like oh god it's happening it's
happening I was [ __ ] myself it was
terrible and I'm in the middle of the
office in the middle of day I had to be
on this call in like five minutes
and I just as a grown-ass woman had just
pooped myself and so I like run down to
the bathroom I get in the bathroom
all three stalls are occupied all three
I'm like oh god what I do and it are out
of paper towels they're out of paper
towels in the bathroom I'm just like oh
my god this is my nightmare how does
this happen so I run down from the
bathroom back into the office to like
grab my car keys to go home to my office
mate just she I had to have smelled like
it's disgusting
No and so I grabbed my bag and I just
run and I'm like oh no do I take the
elevator what if I get stuck in the
elevator with someone ended up going
around the stairs ran down to the stairs
but I'm like how do I set my car so I
take my floor mat put it into my car
seat and I'm like driving home as fast
as I can I jump into the shower fully
clothes rinse off change my clothes and
go back to work and yeah I remember
later that day I was talking to someone
in the office I was like so it's like I
think I have Giardia and she's like you
know you know if you have Giardia I was
like just looked at her I was like I
know what is my secret it's more than
being confused and more than being
afraid and more than I want to find my
voice and have the courage to say you
know the Beatles say listen do you want
to know a secret do you promise not to
tell and then they say I'm in love with
you maybe it's hard for me to love
myself but at the same time it's
happening
[Music]
hey guys Ryan here just wanna let you
guys know that to be safe I do have a
mark on the ground so people are far
enough from the mic not to touch it
also after every single person goes I
make sure to clean the mic you never be
too careful right
I love you guys I hope you're staying
safe make sure to subscribe if you want
if not it's all good no hard feelings
alright bye